Buongiorno a tutti ragazzi e Welcome
Back to Resident e cibo e noi siamo
all'episodio 6 Buona visione ragazzi
perché Perché cazzo ne so poi siamo in
basso cioè perché non ho capito E quindi
Oh che è pronto
Io volevo andare a casa ma Ashley ci
tenevo a vedere il castello
mi fa morire questo Comunque grazie e
lanciarazzi ad esempio
ok
ma questo come cazzo fa ad essere
ovunque come come ti muovi che c'hai un
drone sotto il culo come va in giro lui
No sono a destra sono si sono il
castello Ah fai quel cazzo che ti pare
tanto a quel punto cioè lui gira lui
gira non si sa come qua c'è il mercato
eh cazzo oh oh dovete stare calmi tutti
quanti Mi scusi
in vendita e speriamo ogni volta lo dice
però ci ha mai un cazzo Ma scusami
una carabina semiautomatica
Stai zitto che sto parlando
Broken Butter Ah minchia munizioni
Magnum ragazzi Questo è fortissima ci
sono due nuove armi Questa c'ha uno
spazio Cioè per mettere questa qua Devo
prendere un'altra valigetta però
comunque semiautomatica utilizza i colpi
della carabina che sono i colpi Bianchi
questa utilizza le munizioni Magnum ed è
in offerta speciale io non posso Non
comprarla in questo momento quindi
compriamo subito io il residentivol ho
sempre utilizzato le Magnum perché cioè
fanno la differenza tra così anche
questa volta Let's go e la chiave per
gli altarini non ho capito se posso cioè
se mi serve ancora no però va bene il
dubbio Ragazzi allora Io vendo il
lanciafrecce perché tanto con i
potenziamenti lo vendi Cioè comunque ti
tiene conto anche di potenziamenti ma io
potenzierei la Broken Brother of life io
me la Max ragazzi nella Max ho già di
Potenza perché secondo me
Ok Madonna questa leva 21 a colpo raga è
fortissima se la doppietta la utilizzo
in situazioni di necessità la magnum
proprio solo coi boss praticamente che
se no qua è finita eh vabbè oh Guarda
qua c'è qua tutto questo intanto dietro
il Mercante va bene A stronzo Ma ti sei
inte sei accorto che ci sta già roba qua
poi te la rivende è roba tua Eh l'ho
presa le la rivendo subito quindi
ragazzuoli è il momento allora 76 colpi
anzi di più di di questo comunque i
ragazzi di tutte le armi qua sono
straforti eh perché lo strapotenziato
cos'è che esce di qua Ah
Che cazzo è
Questi sono i sacerdoti raga Sono dei
delle dita nel culo cioè io ve lo giuro
Adesso appena toglieranno con un tappeto
rosso appena li vedrete lo capirete
ragazzi però spero non sia troppo presto
Tra poco perché se no sono cazzi questi
qua sono fortissimi E tra l'altro in
Resident Evil 4 Ragazzi questi qua
facevano un pezzo stranissimo faceva
tipo
una roba del genere terribile mi sognavo
la notte Oh
vabbè finché non mi cacano
stai zitta che cazzo ne so abbassa la
voce
ma se gli avessi sparato cosa sarebbe
successo cioè mi dovrebbero attaccato
malissimo
Ok
Madonna che casino raga Eh sì perché si
ricollega qua Madonna
che cazzo fate qua
Boh Io andrei poi non lo so vieni qua
Ashley per cortesia ma mi ha visto
perché magari non ha visto Marco bene
non mi ha cagato
Sì ma visto mi sa Eh però incastrato
nelle pale è stupido Meno male spara
talmente forte questa pistola che mi
sembrava la magnum ragazzi che cazzo fa
Oh santo Iddio Ok ok Vai Vai veloce
veloce
Dais non è servita la sega però vabbè
Madonna raga quanti cazzo di colpi ci
vogliono per far fuori uno di questi
mi chiedono sparati 2000 per far fuori
un tizio Cioè ma minchia
mi sembra un po' eccessivo Eh ragazzi Sì
alla grande io a posto però eh Non è che
posso andare avanti qua Uh c'è un piano
vuoi suonare non è che posso andare eh
ficchiamo calci alle cose Ah adesso non
ci sono più i panini normali ci sono
questi Vabbè Carini
non è che posso andare avanti a spray 62
colpi a una sola persona ci devono
morire so cazzi Ok Qua sono passati
tutti quelli teoricamente
Allora questo via
lacrima Viola questa roba giusta che
vendiamo perfetto
very nice
Ah merda
attenzione che questi gli devo schivare
sono cazzi amari tanto qua non arriverà
mai nessuno è inutile che la faccio
venire qui qua
Oh mamma
Ma questi non sono Madonna gli sono
passati due colpi Però il problema è che
ci stanno quelli sul tetto è un bordello
ragazzi Eh devo stare attento qua o gli
sparo Eh no ma sono troppi sono Cecchini
Allora facciamo così
Faccio il giro e Vediamo quanti ne
accoppo l'altro li Magnum già sei colpi
e volendo potrei spacca [__] che
botta che cazzo è successo
no esci Ah sei stupida Ti ho detto
e quindi Porca [__]
e per questo bellissimo motivo dovresti
metterti le mani nel culo e stare ferma
Va bene ok bene hai capito no
ma non sta fermo ma allora sei
rincoglionito Se ti dico di stare fermo
stai ferma
Non sta ferma a quanto pare
[__] Oh esci se muori Ti giuro su
Dio che ti lascio lì devi stare ferma
Madonna Io ci provo a dare ai comandi
non mi caga che devo fare Vedi qua si
può andare No
sei stronza proprio ci godo No niente
Non ho colpito Dai vieni Che cazzo ti
devo dire
Salve Porca [__]
Mamma bellissimo è morto non è morto non
è morto non è morto non è mo e non muore
minchia cazzo
devi schioppare se Ti svuoto perfetto
Qua ci stanno catapultando le palle in
faccia che sembra una brutta frase ma
non Oh che cazzo è successo vedi perché
sei rincoglionita se stessi ferma come
ti dico io
Allora ucciso è morto non è morto
non lo vedo è tutto buio Non vedo una
sega corriamo Vediamo che succede
c'è una porta in apribile secondo me
non hanno Ah quindi non Mirano mai
direttamente che Allora niente Volevo
aprire la casa punta io ragazzi Vabbè
'sti cazzi Ah no forse devo andare io
sulla catapulta a spararla sulla porta
Cioè forse non lo so vediamo
Arrivederci minchia ogni volta Sento il
rumore delle rotule è bellissima No
niente ok
Va bene Allora fino non so quanto sia
lontana sta catapulta io ci vado
dobbiamo lasciare qua riesci corri come
se non ci fosse un Tomorrowland
Oddio c'è pure un tizio bastardo Oh
mollala Porca [__] Cioè mi devi seguire
la zia devi seguirmi perché sennò qua
schioppiamo tutte e due corri
bravissima
ok Qua sotto
c'è un cannone e non intendo quelli di
tipo Spinelli Quelli sono per scambiare
gli oggettivi qua la zia mi sta seguendo
è uscito il cazzo sei Eccola perfetto ma
che C'ho l'ansia qua Ah devo attivare il
meccanismo è come attivo ma questo
ok Vabbè bastava dirlo prima ragazzi con
questo mi si si ho capito lo spara alla
porta Ashley ci sei perché qua è un
casino eh Te lo dico Praticamente posso
passare
ma di quella Scusate usufruisco della
mia scrivania anche per queste cose
allora vediamo se riusciamo a curarci
[__] ok perfetto
Non ho più un cazzo perché il timing non
è dalla tua parte Io questo l'ho visto
da un'ora Se riuscissi a seccarlo Ok
Nike e allora Fatemi sotto Porca [__] è
esagerato Madonna quanti cazzo sono ma
se io spacco la porta ne escono altri 9
curiosità non è non mi sembra però no
era perché era per accumularli ragazzi
non so pazzo
che aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta
oh yeah E godereccia questa cosa se
posso permettermi cheat però Sì è vero
lo è parecchio ragazzi Madonna che figo
è stato un disastro raga Minchia ma che
casino si è creato cioè veramente non ho
parole beh c'è da dire che non passiamo
inosservati almeno eh Cioè non avrà
sentito Everywhere Però vabbè ci siamo
entriamo Madonna non mi ricordo più
niente però questa parte era un casino e
si è visto si è visto
fratello c'ho roba per te ho bisogno di
spinelli
questo come fa a viaggiare da un posto
all'altro non lo so grazie zio
Allora potenziare le armi teoricamente
non mi serve perché c'ho tutto al
massimo Quindi boh vabbè lacrime Viola
le vendiamo Ragazzi a me servono 9 Di
sti cosi perché mi serve il calcio della
Red 9 ma 100% proprio
c'è una madonna al contrario
Ok me lo sogno la notte sto posto È un
incubo Un caloroso benvenuto
la sua conoscenza di questo qua
che diavolo sei Non mi ricordo come si
chiama Ramon
quella fanciulla guarda lo farei super
volentieri C'è solo un peso però certo
signor Kennedy signor Kennedy che
cavalli è Io ho una skincare gliela
farei questo
usando lei come fonte primaria gli Stati
Uniti e poi il mondo intero strariperà
della sua Grazia
Questa è la volontà del mio padrone
l'onnipotente
Lord San
le Allora obbedirà gli ordini vera Sì sì
dopo essere arrivato fin qua Ah fa lei
che l'ospite si senta
aca ma io non ho scelto questo l'hai
scelto tu però vabbè a fanno loro quei
due ammazza Quelli sono grossi
secondo me secondo me sono cazzi faccio
io con la pistolina Ma io giusto pure
che dire
Vediamo se funziona no te regalo
Porca [__] Potresti controllare almeno
che non ci arrivi nessuno da dietro
Ashley Ma giusto perché a questo non
voglio fare gli headshot ok
Ok sono morti Ti è piaciuta mercante
l'ho fatta bene Secondo me me la sono
cavata Tanto poi sono tutte robe che
vendo a te Madonna che casino
un po' di pescetas Grazie ragazzi
veramente è stato illuminante Uh c'è
qualcosa qua dietro che un cancello
completamente Qua c'è un cassetto si può
aprire Sì ciò che la chiave Che culo Che
culo che culo assurdo
barra d'oro Nice è andata bene finora
fai tutto tuo eh perché sennò
Minchia Finalmente si rende utile Vamos
attenta
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai veloce
Porca [__]
Ok thank you e continuiamo da questa
parte dove volevi andare Lion
attenzione Madonna che brutto giorno
Buongiorno
Mi fate incazzare questo è vivo
nessuno fuggirà
Vabbè capita anche scrivere su su un
foglietto non è che devi per forza c'è
gente appesa al muro Non ti muovere Per
favore
poveraccio Che brutto modo di morire ma
non ho idea di come siamo magari gli
hanno sparato il cazzo ne sai
Ok Madonna che schifo E qua sta
diventando abbastanza horror ragazzi
come se non lo fosse abbastanza
Ah è proprio che cazzo è che ne so
proprio animali fidati
No stavo pensando ma qua è proprio una
camera di Torto sono le prigioni Minchia
se quelli di fuori sono ridotti così
nelle prigioni come cazzo stanno messi
male comunque spoiler Ma male molto male
hamburger
Chiari sotterranei bella
la luce è
amoerto alla Lux Ok la luce è perduta
Porca [__] che spavento che la vedevo
che stava lì ferma Adesso ho capito
perché Grazie di avermi avvertito
Questo vuol dire che non devo pensare a
lei per un po' che non è male giorno
Buongiorno Questa sarà la copertina del
video immagino Mannaggia oaz
a non ti vede abbastanza stare zitti
ok
Ma si può muovere questo qua
a noi inchiodato al muro [__] vacca
io me ne vado Grazie è stato arrivederci
Ma se lo faccio fuori
si è liberato ragazzi dubito che non si
sia Liberato quindi me ne vado
noia che male che male che male che
dolore forte ho fatto gli spaiati a
toccare il coso fatto in un casino già
stai zitto zitto È tipo un clicker di
della sua fase questo qua ma se gli
sparo dietro che cazzo succede proviamo
a farlo fuori raga Vediamo che succede È
un po' è un po' rischia perché secondo
me è un po' grosso Ho tirato fuori la
magnum Eh ragazzi ma perché più che
altro Secondo me se mi metto a sbloccare
la porta questo mi sente Beh proviamoci
dai
mi sembra effettiva la magnum cioè
proprio una bijoux bijoux
Berillo Roma Porca [__] visto che tanto
avrei fatto un casino che è la metà
bastava Tanto valeva farlo fuori ragazzi
cioè non potevo
farmi i cazzi mia perfetto Arrivederci
Io proprio ad agire Stealth 0 nella vita
completamente Ciao Ashley sono qua fatto
un po' di casino ma tutto a posto eh
niente Cioè eravamo al bar
più o meno
Per adesso sì Tanto sono io che affronto
i giganti dicono otto braccia e le mani
di Wolverine Stai tranquilla zia ci
manca solo che ti lamenti te guarda
bello siamo in cantina che hai sempre
meglio del sotterraneo a questo punto
uno spinello lo vuoi Tanto lo so che ti
fai dire Eccola qua a proposito c'è un
rumore Vabbè sticazzi
Ok Chi è che ha scassato tutto qua
Che minchia è 'sto coso Aquila Cervo
bilancia serpente va bene grazie tipo
Grifondoro sempre
Ah mi sa che devo colpirli in ordine può
essere così devo fare
Aquila Cervo bilancia serpente va bene
aquila e dove cazzo è Eccola
Cervo che non lo vedo però cervo e poi
il serpente No che però è là
e poi Ah ok [__] io c'abbiamo 'sta
bilancia Ma che cazzo era Salve Devo
rubare una spada qua spada insanguinata
va bene a mettermela nel culo escile ma
che domande fai Minchia ma anche tu ma
veramente io non so io non posso fare
sta vita costa qua Eh ve lo dico già
Ma va Te lo devi farlo tu prossima volta
fai te io non voglio sapere niente di
sti enigmi
Allora vediamo un attimo questo qua mi
piace e bel badona Quanto vorrei fare
questa cosa entrare spaccare tutto nelle
cose senza un motivo vero calci a
manetta o la vipera occhio De Murta
Thank you e Qua abbiamo saccheggiato
siamo tornati nella parte principale
Ancora ste merde di cose allora vediamo
un po'
il serpente e due Minchia eh Dai
dall'altra parte Madonna Brava niente
spacco tutto
Eccolo là lo vedo aspetta
preso Yes ce l'ho fatta arrivo
non ho ancora ben capito chi è che fa
ste cose che mettesti enigmi Però vabbè
ci siamo
Ma se non avessi dei colpi per fare
questa cosa come potrei sbloccarle
queste cose ci lancio le pietre Scusami
e finalmente
potevi anche aprirla più piano Lion
Madonna
munizioni magnum Che culo che Bucio de
culo Oh
Thank you Dillo ti prego
va bene lo stesso
no però c'ho la magnum volendo che penso
che alla fine sia il miglior modo andare
a cazzo e vedere che succede
c'è la Madonna qua Raga ho trovato
un'altra munizione alla Magnum
lo immagino dove cazzo arrivano Porca
[__]
e attenta Tu più che attento Io
no ma più che altro perché c'è gente che
mi spara da lontano
Mamma mia ragazzi che terribile
situazione
No vabbè ma è orribile ci penso io
tranquillo uno due
merda Tre Che culo che culo
Che culo atroce non so come ho fatto
passare
Ok ok Non male Non male ma è andato
anche di culo mi sa
Madonna Ok perfetto ma che cazzo serve
sta roba Ah io devo ficcare qualcosa qua
in tutto sto casino perché c'è un coso
dove devo ficcare una roba Beh ottimo
Vabbè scendiamo vediamo che riusciamo a
fare ragazzi Anche se la vedo grigia
c'è un cazzo Sì Madonna Sì però Ragazzi
fatevi Un bucio di cazzi vostri
bene
pure
Non è vero che devo ricaricare adesso
Oh Madonna raga
E vabbè E non ho più colpi Raga io non è
che posso fa attenzione
Madonna come ho fatto non so eh via le
palle sì però attenzione qua perfetto
Ma sai che mi è andata pure bene Si è
mandata veramente bene Non so neanche
come ho fatto che culo
forse che sta per una volta me la sono
cavata per bravura e non per culo ma
penso sia l'unica volta nella storia dei
videogiochi per quanto mi riguarda Ah
c'era pure il coso da far saltare in
aria Vabbè dai 'sti cazzi L'importante è
che ce l'abbiamo fatta Allora aspetta
che qua c'è qualcosa
Ah no Eccolo altro che lì ho trovato la
ruota che devo mettere di sopra ma come
torno di sopra e quello è il problema
pure mi stanno spara chi è che mi sta
sparando Ah eccolo
Vai ficca ficca ficca gira gira veloce
Ok
qualcuno me la deve spiegare sta roba
comunque cioè veramente strana Ma chi
cazzo Chi è che ha progettato sta stanza
tutte domande che non avranno mai
risposta la donna ma che cazzo io
Madonna se vi piglio Anzi a te ti piglio
tu sei qua
ti stacco Ahia tua madre morta ieri
Mannaggia veramente a chi t'è muort E
vabbè è morto e quindi Mannaggia pure a
lui attenzione che devo salire da
qualche parte Ah devo ficcarlo qua il
coso mi ha fatto pure male Sto stronzo
logorroico c'è tuo padre al massimo ok
è morto è morto è morto non è morto
morto
è morto adesso mi sa che è morto
Sì sì quello che dici tu Allora vediamo
se riesco a tirar fuori staffare prima
che mi sparino in 27 in faccia cosa che
dubito
Chissà perché ho il dubbio di riuscire
che non ci riuscirò Eh non ce l'ho fatta
invece incredibile Non chiedetemi come
ma ha funzionato veramente Va bene ok
ragazzi siamo arrivati all'altra
manovella che non ho idea cosa mi possa
servire ma è se muoio devo rifarmi tutto
da capo quindi speriamo di no stai bene
io Io sto bene lei non me ne frega un
cazzo Sinceramente però gira sta
manovella perché già era un dito in culo
sta parte o no me lo ricordavo io la
famiglia stronzo
ah devo fare a merda non è manca un
pezzo
manca ancora un pezzo E dove lo faccio
Ah devi andare qua su esci Non mi
chiedere che devi fare però devi andare
su vieni così lui sa vieni ma che cazzo
io non Ripigliati fatti i fatti di meno
Ok che stai usando erba dall'inizio del
gioco
c'è gente là eh
lì io Stai tranquillo Li
[__] va
Ma dov'è la
quindi devo coprirla da qui guarda che
non c'ho tutta sta Mira io Eh non li
prendo da un millimetro devo prendere da
qua
il prossimo vedi di muoverti perché qua
devi fare in fretta ancora una eh mi
serve un'altra Però sono stato bravo Sì
sì basta che ti muovi Come cazzo hai
attenta che c'è il tizio qua attenta
Stai attenta bravissima
Oh merda
E vabbè ma c'è troppa gente questo gioco
di merda Cosa devo fare qua porca [__]
tu non c'ha veramente guarda
Lion pure
sono io un cazzo devo Oh io sto attento
a quello che fa lei o sta attento a
quello che faccio io non è che posso fa
tutto io
non ci credo ho sparato a è morta
ma non ci voglio credere ho sparato a ma
è morta veramente quindi non c'ho Meno
male che non mi ha fatto rifare tutto
guarda che se no esci li Muoviti
Mannaggia Guarda Porca [__] guarda
che io devo stare attento a quelli lì
suoi e non ai miei Dai buttati giù è
finita Esci e ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi
teoricamente
non stai tranquillo non scendono
scendono corri corri corri Brutta
stronza Maria corri
corri sei corri vieni qua vieni qua
vieni qua capito un cazzo hai capito
Madonna di Dio ho perso tutte le
dimensioni della pistola avevo un
miliardo non ne ho più Meno male che me
l'ha ridate adesso più o meno Madonna
veramente
stai bene una sega lì non è stato
terrificante Andiamo avanti vediamo se
riusciamo a proseguire in sto Castello
del cazzo non c'è qualcosa qua Ah deve
pure andare lei neanche io Vabbè vai tu
devi aprire tu mi sai zia
Mi apri la porticina Ti prego grazie Non
è il momento di morire Dopo lo fai
grazie Ok adesso mi devo far venire il
fegato marcio per una sembra il posto
giusto io
stai bene Che palle vomitati addosso
stai benissimo in Fiore
a caccia [__] che male
stai indietro ragazzo
Ma che cazzo è Ma da quando
Oh merda
e quindi ferma non vai vai vai vai ti
voglio più vedere vai vai vai pure cazzo
vero fermati
a terribile
capitolo 7 ragazzi l'orrore l'orrore di
residenti
è andato tutto a [__] Grazie
Ormai tutti adesso mi manda un attimino
in ritardino e mi dicono va Potevate
fare un po' dopo ma già che c'eravate
prendetevela comoda no
Trova Ashley Non so come sia possibile e
c'è il Mercante Però tra l'altro non
capisco come faccia ad arrivare in tutti
un po' Guarda la giornata più brutta di
questa è stata quando ho fatto la
maturità Poi per il resto Uh c'è
un'altra pistola la black Tail il
giubbino tattico che protegge
completamente quindi con questo qua ma
mi occupa spazio nell'inventario no me
lo prendo sì mi aumenta la difesa Ma
certo non lo prendo Ma siete pazzi Mi
manca solo uno spinello e non pensate
male perché comprarmi il calcio è l'area
di 9 che teoricamente mi dà un sacco di
precisione Matilda c'è anche un'altra
arma Matilda bellissima Beh devo
prendere il calcio per la Red nove ma mi
manca uno spinello singolo va bene my
boys mi sono potenziato anche l'armatura
adesso Dovrebbero levarmi teoricamente
di meno e ho bisogno di sto maledetto
spinello Fottutissimo perché mi Vi giuro
con quello là aumento la precisione la
mia arma di tantissimo c'è proprio mi
serve tantissimo se riuscissi a trovarlo
[__]
ok no Giusti Cosi ti prego dimmi che non
ci arrivo quello che devi stare in
silenzio Questa è gente viva No Questa
gente è morta Ok Porca [__] che ansia
Salve ma che diavolo è che cazzo ne so
io è un action figures un po' grande ma
è un action figures
riponi la fiamma cremisi in un luogo
appropriato affinché tu venga illuminato
il percorso svelato la fiamma cremisi
questa
devo prenderla e portarla qua può essere
vediamo
c'è gente poco raccomandabile qua dentro
però entriamo Questo l'avevo sentito zio
ho capito e non c'è bisogno di far
casino Però io gli ho detto che ho
capito basta che possiamo inosservati
anche se dubito posso lasciare
posso lasciare Uh che cazzo No piano
piano che fa casino piano Ah non fare
così non non attira gente va bene Magari
non se ne accorgono che passo non so
come terminiamo fare piano eh devo fare
piano Io ci provo Poi fai tu C'è un
esplosivo e Ricordiamocelo
bene bene bene due esplosivi ottimo
Cos'è che devo prendere una lanterna
cremisi Salve Avevo visto questo
bene Beh zitta zitta zitta zitta zitta
zitta che fai casino
Ok Minchia che bordello devo farlo fuori
per forza perché è girato però ce la
faccio Teoricamente
mi piacciono ste parti che sono Stealth
visto Cioè ci sono le parti stent non ha
senso questo devo fare qua
no cioè non fa casino Eh mi sa che ve ne
siete accorti che c'è qualcuno
se ne sono accorto agli ho schiacciati
tutti
lo volevo far saltare Arca [__] che
male beh me ne vado Arrivederci non ben
capito che devo fare Ah ho capito cosa
devo fare Devo prendere devo prenderlo
da lui il coso sei tu che ce l'hai testa
di merda Me lo dai il coso che c'hai
prima Grazie questo La Lanterna mi serve
La Lanterna me la dai Lanterna Lanterna
che Dio tanto bene Mi serve la lanterna
l'ho presa via via via via via via via
via veloce veloce veloce Arrivederci
Porca [__]
teoricamente l'ho trovato eh vediamo se
riesco a farcela
Ok ora sciato ma fotte sega ok no
aprilo veloce ma proprio velocissimo
tipo velocissimo grazie grazie gentile
eh Via via via via via via via via via
via via via via via che ansia però la
parte esterna mi è uscita abbastanza
bene ragazzi poteva andare peggio molto
peggio
Chissà dov'è Quella minchiona che poi
guarda quando ci sono io è pieno di
gente quando è da sola non se la caga
nessuno sta cosa me la devono spiegare
non sarà tanto lontano se posso usare
Ashley per arrivare in quel punto
Purtroppo non è tanto lontana
[Musica]
Ah la stragnocca Meno male
Aspettavo questo momento dall'inizio del
gioco vero
dopo ben 6 anni Questo è il saluto che
mi merito si conoscono
è interessante
ma minchia veramente
dovreste essere alleati per il corpo a
corpo non sono per niente
perché stai lavorando stavolta
[Musica]
Madonna che gnocca atomica l'ho già
detto ragazzi Lo so lo so però eh Che
devo fa sarà il vestito non lo so
dimenticala è spacciata In ogni caso
Forse ci rincontreremo
saluto che desideravi
credimi e Renda così facilmente
non chi non faccio domande ragazzi
Rimandiamo alla conversazione a un'altra
volta ti va
Sono andata alla fine spider-man lei è
spider-man spider-man
va bene
molto simpatica
no l'ultima persona che ti aspetti qua è
ad esempio Alessandra Amoroso però vabbè
pietra litografica B Ok Ado ficcarle
tutte qua dentro pure penso che una sia
nello scrigno quello che posso aprire Ah
ce n'è un'altra qua
l'ho presa con pietra litografica de la
prendiamo subito Ah ce n'è un'altra e
manca ne manca una Magari nella stanza
non la vedo sono nascoste tutte qua non
ho sbagliato io prima Ok Ah ma l'altra è
incastrata Sono stupido una lo scudo Ah
no sono due
ma c'è retro Allora era giusta Ah no
perché c'è un esagono questa forma di
esagono E allora mi sa che qua dietro Ce
n'è un Eccola perfetto
Vamos
che ce l'hai fatta è sicuro non ho
capito
rumore bruttissimo
topi devo trovare Ashley Grazie di
avermelo ricordato però te lo
dimenticassi guarda
ho visto un coso tipo ragno Già è
complicato Adesso figuriamoci coi ragni
Raga non mi fate mi fate prendere male
[Applauso]
Cristo
Ti prego che cazzo devo fare
Mamma mia che schifo ragazzi che schifo
che vomito andatevene a [__] tutti ma
dimmi Teo Che merda
[Musica]
stai giù
non ho capito Mamma mia ragazzi sto cosa
sta diventando sto gioco Infatti
tu che cazzo fai nella vita spiega puoi
essere ovunque
in ogni istante vediamo se riesco c'è
gente lì già la vedo da qua guarda va
bene Ti vendo due robe Eh lo Stingray
Vabbè dai prendiamolo sto maledetto con
30 kws
un campo di zucchero Grazie della tua
delle tue perle me lo potenzio già eh
raga perché tanto sono armi che
utilizzerò per sempre quindi già che ci
sono Vai vai
Perfetto Perfetto
[Musica]
A metà dello spazio occupato dalle armi
ma neanche posso provare a utilizzare
queste Ok
Non male
Beh dai è fortissimo raga Minchia oh
beve Minchia li ho seccati tutti
fighissima
cazzo che ride ancora quello
mi hai preso per un gabbiano
una volta bella devo colpire questo
ok
era era intuibile in realtà sono io che
sono stupido
Buongiorno
Facciamo così Guardavo un regalo
Madonna che mirabex sulle granate c'è
Che cazzo è aiuto
provo a usare il cecchino Vediamo che
succede
Madonna Madonna
Beh però lo SNAI però è forte ragazzi lo
sniperone è forte non gli si può dire
niente veramente fortissimo Vabbè almeno
mi sono skillato e abbiamo capito che fa
la differenza andiamo avanti ragazzi
curiosità è la mia cos'è questo
Ok uh
chi cazzo l'aveva visto Oh dove cazzo è
Oh che schifo
Che merda sti cosi raga Madonna sono la
cosa più brutta di sto gioco finora so
fatti veramente bene rendono proprio
l'idea di ragno Oddio
No no
Meno male che meno male che l'ho fatto
fuori prima
Ok
Nice Minchia che vi costa la meno
spinello mi serve quel [__] calcio
sono Star ma è scarsissima cioè non è
scarpe da te è fortissima però vada
sempre a culo già la mira mia fa schifo
aggiungiamoci pure che l'arma non è
precisa
porca [__] porca
bene
è una tipa questa
devi stare calmo
Perfetto Io ormai tiro leve a caso Raga
non sto capendo manco io cosa sto
aprendo lo sto chiedendo Salve Sì sì
quello che dici tu
morto va bene
oddio Benedetto la gente ha dove esce
qua
Che cazzo è
No merda ho sparato con la magnum non
volevo sparare con la magnum Minchia
L'ho sciolto ho sparato un colpo di
Magnum senza volerlo merda Questo non è
un buon segno perché prima non vanno
tenuti fino alla fine ragazzi però vabbè
ormai l'ho sparato c'è altra gente qua
Sì c'è altra gente qua c'è proprio la
risposta è che c'è altra gente proprio
c'è altra gente la vedo non ci posso
credere
credo che questo sia un po' più
incazzato dell'altro comunque ma devo
sparargli con le armi normali ma corro
cazzo devo fare
una merda lui mi lancia le cose sembra
di me Ragazzi comunque il del Ring
Questo gioco è pure ci manca solo la
sveglia in questa merda di che sta
succedendo ci va solo quello mancava ok
Porca [__] chi cazzo sei muori
Ok
Quanti minchia che male siete Allora
aspetta che mi devo curare non ho tanta
vita ragazzi attenzione
perfetto
la gente qua Uh Buongiorno Non ti avevo
visto a te
te ne sei [__] Ma io ti ho sparato in
bocca e te ne sei [__] Vabbè mi
sembra giusto Aspetta OK
Mi sa che sono un po' tanti Mannaggia
Chiudi chiudi la porta
Oh io devo vedere che devo andare di
preciso sono andati sotto o scendere
scendi
non mi faccio domande non so perché mi
sa che sono nella merda perché se salgo
qua mi colpiscono
No non mi ha colpito va bene
Ah c'è il cannone Meno male meno male
meno male Meno male meno male Fammelo
prendere azioni Eh speriamo che funzioni
Quello sicuro Il problema è che devo
attivarlo Ah ok perfetto vai
chi cazzo sei Batman
Ok niente male vero
vabbè me ne fotto me ne fotte proprio di
sopra così random
anche qua devo farlo salire pure e già
che è un casino va bene
ok
E mo
Vabbè al Cannone ci siamo arrivati però
non so
un colpo per un colpo
teoricamente è morto minchia lo seccato
anche lui mi ha beccato Però mi ha fatto
anche molto male Se devo essere sincero
Vabbè c'è ancora uno lì
Perfetto Mi sa che è morto eh
ok E ci siamo e ci siamo io penso che mi
sto allontanando tantissimo da Ashley Ah
no ma mi butto di sopra che pirla Ah
senti scendi scendi scendi
yessa ci siamo ragazzi figo Mi scusi eh
non volevo fa' che proprio è più forte
di me è stato l'ho vista lì e ho detto
vabbè
che comunque
che comunque va bravo lo so come Conte
Ah merda Cazzo siamo nel Signore degli
anelli Lo devo seccare Ah è morto
è morto è morto adesso è morto
abbastanza
mi sa che è morto Minchia Però fino
all'ultima dovuto rompere le palle
questo qua eh Figurati figurati
ok
Oh finalmente l'interno del Castello
pieno di merda Ashley dove sei Ma che
cazzo te ne frega vottitene di che morte
è morta hai provato tu il tuo dovere
l'hai fatto ma tra l'altro
volevo dire che indietro ci hanno pezzi
che potevo fare con Ashley quindi non
vorrei che poi alla fine Eccola
Ma che cazzo ci fai qua che ho
attraversato i giganti ad stagione 2 di
Attack on Titan hanno superato
Sì sì volentieri tu
Hai già fatto tante volte
quando è successo
Non ero io ero qualcosa altro deve
essere terrificante lo so
la merda anche Lion Beh sì certo
è normale avere paura
ma non puoi scappare
devi andare avanti
possiamo farcela
insieme
e poi effettivamente se Paolo ha la cura
effettivamente ci può anche stare prima
di accoltellarmi ancora
Che simpatico che è
Grazie a te
possiamo levarci dai [__] Grazie
Arrivederci al capitolo termina pure e
quindi ragazzi anche questo episodio di
Resident Evil è finito ma spero che vi
sia piaciuto come sta piacendo a me e
come sempre io vi ringrazio per la
visione lasciate un bel commento mi
piace iscrivetevi al canale Se non siete
ancora iscritti ma dubito se siete
arrivati fino qua che non siete iscritti
al canale se no siete iscrivetevi e noi
ci vediamo al prossimo episodio bella
ragazzi